now to Matthew Perry yeah the French
star is on a media blitz for his new
book and just when you think that he is
right out of shockers oh no there's so
much more
my heart did stop for five minutes
Jennifer one day came up and said we
know you're drinking we could smell it
how desperate did it get for the friend
star well Matthew says that during the
pandemic he was so determined to get
Oxycontin he spent 350 thousand dollars
to fly a round trip from Switzerland to
La I flew back on a private jet and it
cost me a cool 175 thousand dollars to
do so back in La I went to see my doctor
I need 1800 milligrams a day I said oh
no she said we're not giving you that at
all cancer patients only get 100
milligrams that very same night I booked
another 175 thousand dollars private jet
and flew right back to Switzerland
listen that was pocket change for
Matthew who along with his co-stars was
making one million dollars per episode
for Seasons nine and ten of friends as
for his current royalties from
syndication could I be more sorry
would you characterize them as Bountiful
checks or would you say it's a trickle
at this point well yesterday I bought
Iowa
[Applause]
I did yeah so they're Bountiful checks
uh they're not bad and they come as a
form of a text you just made this and I
go oh green Matt also opened up about
losing a major role in the movie don't
look up I got CPR and the guy who saved
my life broke eight ribs in the process
I woke up in a different hospital 10
hours later I had to give up you know
this amazing movie that I got the best
biggest movie I've ever gotten I had
four scenes with Meryl Streep I say we
sit tight and assess
Matthew had a super supportive reception
last night in New York where he
discussed the release of his Memoir
friends lovers and the big terrible
thing he also took questions from fans
including who was his favorite friend's
guest star I think Sean's back
would you give me a kiss
you always no Bunny at all
[Music]